vous êtes certainement à la maison
surtout ne vous disputez pas avec votre
conjoint avec votre femme avec vos
enfants et essayer de l'est qui fait les
chéris parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
me disent ouais on va rester confiné
alors je vous donnerai dans un instant
les dix raisons pour rester confinés et
être contents et qui fait vous le savez
il est impératif pour notre sécurité
je vous le dis de rester à la maison
donc moi je vous ai lister les 10 choses
voilà qui vont faire que vous allez être
contents d'être à la maison puisqu'il
est impératif de limiter les
déplacements
le plus possible en a plein qui disait
on va déprimer on va s'ennuyer on va
autres au bout du rouleau mais non alors
on numéro 10 c'est enfin l'occasion de
faire connaissance avec sa femme est
important les ja non mais sans déconner
ouais mais c'est comme ça bon mois battu
les a jamais vus allez pas là tu vas
passer 45 joueurs avec eux parce que je
voulais bien s'arrête 15 + 15 + 15
je me dis tout de suite en dixième
position donc c'est enfin l'occasion de
faire connaissance avec sa femme et ses
enfants de rester confinés en neuvième
position grâce au télétravail
vous allez enfin pouvoir faire popo au
boulot sans avoir honte en sortant des
toilettes c'est quand vous le savez
quand vous êtes tranquillement en train
d'aller aux toilettes et vous sortez
vous savez pas si vous allez tomber sur
la meuf de la drh que vous qui fait si
vous allez tomber sur le legs de la
contacter vous kiffez et balla vous
allez aux toilettes tranquille vous êtes
en télétravail bim et là vous arrivez
toujours frais bim ti maquillage et tout
ça itunes est allé bien on les beaux
gosses en plus on peut mettre des
lunettes de soleil parce qu on dit que
c'est pour le coronavirus donc voilà
donc ces beaux gosses on est bien on les
tranquilles on est d'accord position bah
vous subirez plus la mauvaise haleine de
votre collègue c'est maintenant sa femme
qui l'a suivi tatin de jouer avec eux on
le sait il fait pas grave se veut aussi
des problèmes gastriques des trucs comme
ça tu as toujours un gars qui a une
haleine chelou non mais c'est vrai on
avait toujours qui donne à manger du
taboulé mon frère sur une manière moi
j'essaie toujours celui qui te parlent
tous prêts à mais le gars qui publie
toujours le gars qui veut dire des
secrets mais maintenant on s'en fout
maintenant on est encore aux navires us
à son on est loin et voilà je vous le
dis sinon
on a en septième position on n'a plus le
droit d'aller à la salle de sport on a
donc enfin une super excuses pour avoir
un gros cube novembre sur la place
moi c'est ce que je vais dire cet été un
mois je vais avoir un corps dégueulasse
je vous lis bas qu'est ce que je vais
dire frères très sort du corps un avion
histoire que tu veux champ de
confinement tu crois quoi j'étais en
train de manger toute la journée
frère d'emma crude et des trucs parce
que ma mère je peux vous dire quand elle
est en confinement croyez qu'elle fait
quoi un vert très bas le fait des bouts
scouts où j'ai ma croûte des croquants
et d d d d d d d longue gâteau qu'on les
connaît même pas les invente mon frère
ça veut dire qu'elle met plus d'huile et
de miel ça veut dire si il ya si on est
en pénurie d'huile de miel on va chez ma
mère directement je peux vous dire en
amas crude et ben al adel a sauvé toute
la toute toute la france maintenant les
jeudis sinon j'aimerais aussi pour
montrer comment moi aussi vous détendre
c'est à dire vous détendre chez vous et
il ya des gestes très simples
corporelles à faire pour se détendre et
pour se défouler un petit peu à part le
sport c'est vrai ça c'est des gestes de
danse
moi je suis avant tout intense heures à
jouer mais le dancing
alors j'aimerais qu'on mettre un petit
peu de musique et je vous montrer les
gestes à faire pour chez vous vous
détendre tout et sa muse 1
regarde ça
[Musique]
si vous vous ennuyez d'être envoyé deux
honda va les battre et demain l'antenne
non
je ne méritais pas oula tu es attaquant
qui est allé moi ça m'a fait sourire à
sa vente pas cibler une bonne saison
mais donnez tout soit tu es rejeté la tv
dans deux ans maintenant